good morning believe nation in today's
that was at a believe life we're going
to talk about the why and the how of
creating the morning routine my morning
routine is very simple I get up every
morning at 5:00 in the morning
and then I go down sets of the kitchens
that reading the various different
newspapers then go on my iPad to all my
emails and stuff like that facetiming
and some go upstairs to the gym and work
at 45 minutes to an hour do
cardiovascular training
and after that if my breakfast stick
around
jusers opening bid bananas and
strawberries and some blueberries in
depth I mix it all up it's a coffee dad
go dig my shower and then go to work I'm
like an athlete you got to Train your
nervous system
besides physically working out I also
train my mind to do in my emotions to do
what's the most difficult and I do that
all kinds of ways I like to play at my
edge you know that's how you get better
so I put my demands myself but the first
thing I do every morning is part of that
ritual is I jump into Jacuzzi which
loosen the muscles and then I jump in
freezing cold water I have a cold plunge
if you would it's 57 degrees and I hop
into that thing I also for recovery sake
I use cryotherapy which was developed in
Europe it's amazing a lot of athletes
around the world are using it now and it
lowers your body temperature using
nitrogen so there's no water on your you
would freeze it up or you'd burn by
using these gases it brings the
temperature down your body down to minus
225 Fahrenheit which is my wild for
three minutes and what it does is it
like resets your whole nervous system
and it takes all the inflammation out of
your body so I'm on stage I'll do 27
miles on my most intense day of a
three-day program so I'm doing like
multiple days of ultra marathon cuz I'm
not standing there talking I mean people
would not come if B won't sit for a
three hour movie someone spent 300
million dollars on to make for two hours
they're gonna stay with me for 50 hours
over weekend I gotta deliver right and I
got you know the Paul Tudor Jones is the
world in there the Oprah Winfrey's in
the Oprah tells me totally I love you
but I can't see anywhere for more than
two hours and the end of 12 hours you
stand your chair going on camera this is
what the greatest experience of my life
well to do that you're in standing still
I'm plunging the audience I'm doing
things I'm spontaneous so that's a lot
of miles so I'm literally doing one
marathon and I go into this machine and
three minutes later I come out the next
day it's like instead of all these aches
and pains and tears I'm recovered so I'm
always looking for technology that can
enhance my ability to perform and
produce greater results and also stay
healthy you know I wake up really early
every day and I play tennis with
somebody who's
lot younger and a lot fitter than me and
we play singles and you know we give it
everything we can and and you know
sweating big-time and having a lot of
fun as well and then if the wind is up
you know go for a kite surf tithings a
lovely way just to get it get away from
you know the mobile phones and and and
just get you know get out on the sea you
know after that you know come back have
a sort of nice healthy breakfast
generally sometimes you know sometimes
not so healthy I found your kryptonite
then I'm ready for the day what do you
do by 10:00 a.m. yeah it depends what
day depends what's happening around the
world I'll be honest with you though I'm
more of a night guy than a morning yet
so I tend to start my day a little bit
later I'll stay up until like 2 o'clock
at night reading briefings and doing
work typically the girls go to bed a
little bit earlier around 10 11 o'clock
so I wake up at a pretty reasonable hour
usually around 7:00 I'll get a workout
in then the first thing that I have in
the day is what's called the
presidential daily briefing and it is
basically a book full of everything that
went wrong in the world so that I know
what what I'm up against and then I'll
meet with my national security team a
lot of those issues tend to be sort of
urgent emergency issues I may have to
make some quick decisions on that so
usually that's happened around 10:00
10:30 usually before the Sun comes up I
offer myself to something greater than
myself
if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10
minutes I at least stop in that space in
my house every morning I have a little
meditation space where I just go I have
beautiful spiritual readings there I
like my three candles there daily word
or something and I express to this
greater energy feel than I that I don't
want to be alone as I move out into the
world at what time do you get up
normally in the morning for me it's
usually about two seven seven okay but I
go to bed late so usually it's I go to
bed around 1 a.m. or so and you stop day
with a real breakfast or just for the
coffee or with the water you know that
also varies a lot I think it's probably
true that if you thought having a good
breakfast is is a good idea but usually
I don't have time for that so sometimes
sometimes it's it's made for me but
probably half the time I don't have any
breakfast I had let's have like coffee
or something like that one spot sure
well try to cut down on the on sweet
stuff so but I think I mean I think I
probably should have like a an omelet
and a coffee or something like that
that seems like probably the right thing
and sometimes that you have that do you
have a morning ritual I get up I stretch
I light a candle
I meditate for 20 minutes I get myself
together I Drive around the corner I get
my kids I sit with them for 20 minutes
and I take them to school every morning
I can't wait till I wake up in the
morning I and you know what helps me out
a great deal when I wake up in the
morning I spend the first 10 minutes
just thanking him
I don't even address any problems and
stuff I got I'm just grateful that I'm
up for this and I think every little
thing and I'll spend Timothy and it
makes your day start such a wonderful
way to realize that you woke up you hear
you have a latitude meditation for 10
minutes my routines are usually focused
on a numb
of things including clarifying and
confirming what those few things are
that matter so I will wake up I have to
tea every morning but I'll usually wake
up and I'll have I'll do 15 20 minutes
of transcendental meditation then I will
start my tea I'll boil the water or
actually it's 185 degrees so I get very
specifically so I have a Cuisinart
kettle that allows you to pick the
temperature all right ha and 285 degrees
I then I I usually have a combination
that you just like you guys saw earlier
I have this stuff so it's it's puer tea
which is an in aged black tea typically
from China combined with turmeric and
ginger and then I like to add in some
type of green tea oftentimes essentia
and if I'm feeling sick or I feel like
I'm coming down with something I'll add
garlic to that so minced garlic usually
but otherwise that that is sort of my
morning tea and then once I have my tea
I'll sit down and I will do one of two
things I'll either use something called
the five minutes your five minutes first
thing in the morning five minutes right
before you go to bed right and it's
really really helpful for I think
priming your mind for the day and does
that through even three things you're
grateful for
of course you do a identify your
priorities and then having a basically a
performance review before you go to bed
and either that or morning pages so I
will I will freehand Journal and the
intention of that is is not to be a good
writer at the end I think it's
particularly valuable for people who'd
never write or don't write a galley you
know because it allows you to take the
the self-defeating talk or anxieties or
worries that you have your
preoccupations and trap them in the form
of words on a page so that you can get
on with your [ __ ] day that gets us to
let's just say 8:30 9 o'clock at that
point I like to do some some basic
mobility work after that 20 to 30 minute
exercise block I would like to focus on
some type of
tense whether it be writing audio
interviewing etc and then lunch and then
after launches where I do the the grunt
work for research I put in that bucket
right not the rod cast but for research
in autonomous so that's sort of the
first three to four-hour block of most
of my days as you know I'm known to be a
highly productive person I speak a
hundred times a year I write four books
a year I run three businesses I travel
all over the world people say how do you
do it well I have a morning routine and
I developed this a long time ago and it
really works what I do is I always get
up two hours before my next my first
fixed appointment so let's say I have a
phone call at eight o'clock then I get
up at 6 a.m. if I actually be in the
office at 8:30 I'll get up at 6:30 is
always 6:00 6:30 maybe earlier if
necessary but always 2 hours before my
first appointment then the first thing I
do for the first 30 minutes is I
exercise and I'll do stretching
exercises all do yoga exercises
sometimes I'll get up a little earlier
and I'll do aerobic exercises on life
cycle or elliptical machine or treadmill
or a swim
I usually swim every single morning but
for the first 30 minutes get your body
working and then I like coffee then I'll
do a little bit of spiritual reading and
I'll just relax and get my mind ready
for the day and then I'll get started
within 60 minutes of getting up I've
exercise prepared my mind showered
dressed so I'm ready to go then I have
the next hour to plan prepare have
breakfast and get to my first
appointment so give that a try get up
two hours early exercise for the first
30 minutes to get yourself going
read a little to prepare your mind and
then be ready to go one hour before you
have to be somewhere
when you wake up each day let's talk
about productivity in general when you
wake up each day the first thing to do
is not go to the computer the first
thing to do is go exercise go for a walk
take a long shower is to open your body
and engage and in doing that process
whatever it is for you some people it's
a long run some people also longer
shower some people it's a walk around
the neighborhood when you're doing that
here's one to ask yourself a couple of
simple questions first I want you to ask
yourself what am i excited about today
or could I create to be excited about
today so what is it I want you to begin
your day with enthusiasm optimism is the
magical formula that creates greater
happiness in our lives
to have something to look forward to
steal away someone's vision for a good
future and you'll quickly see them fall
into the depression but when we have a
great connection to something in the
future that we look forward to even if
it's just this day that creates the
charge within us so walk around take
your laps do whatever you have to do in
the morning but ask yourself what is it
that I'm excited about today or could be
enthusiastic about today are there any
habits or behaviors needed instill in
yourself to achieve those goals make
those behaviors or habits part of your
morning and evening routines so for
example maybe your goal is to write a
novel this year make writing for 30
minutes uninterrupted the first thing
you do every morning if your goal is to
learn Spanish make studying in a Spanish
grammar book part of your evening
routine and if dropping 30 pounds is
your goal make exercise the first thing
you do in the morning
now while the task you decide to include
in your morning e-meter teens are gonna
vary depending on your goals I'd like to
suggest one habit to include in yours
every evening review the day's work and
plan your day for tomorrow in the
morning review your schedule in your
long and short-term goals I promise if
you do these two things you'll find
yourself more focused and will
accomplish much more during the day one
beneficial habit that you can practice
every morning is to get up and read 30
to 60 minutes in something uplifting and
inspirational each day when you get up
in the morning and instead of reading
the newspaper or watching television you
read something positive and constructive
and inspiring
you set your mental stage or tone for
the rest of the day throughout the day
from the first day that you try this you
will notice that things go better for
you you will be calmer you're more
productive you're more creative you're
more alert you'll actually be more
resilient and will respond more
effectively when you face V&F it'll ups
and downs of your daily life just like
vigorous physical exercise in the
morning will prepare you to be more
resilient physically during the day
positive mental exercise in the form of
inspirational reading will prepare you
to be more mentally fit during the day
my best strategy for maximizing your
morning's probably it probably gets
lumped into categories so the first
thing is manage your energy and not your
time so we often talk about time
management
everybody has 24 hours in the day you
only up certain amount of time to get
things done but that time is relatively
useless if you're if you don't have the
energy to complete the tasks right I've
tried a variety of different times to
lift I did early morning I did like
mid-morning around 10:00 or 11:00 and
then I also tried lifting later in the
evening like 5 to 7 p.m. and for me that
was when I got my best workouts in so
that's when I arranged that task as well
so this idea of managing your energy for
the right tasks and not necessarily just
thinking about getting things done for a
particular time is is very useful the
second thing is thinking about the
distractions that pull you away from
doing good work and when you let those
creep into your day so a lot of people
as soon as they wake up in the morning
they use their phone as their alarm they
look at their phone and then they see a
flood of email Instagram Facebook
whatever and so right away from the very
beginning of the day their mind is
filled with all the other urgencies of
the day they start to respond to someone
else's agenda rather than their own and
I found that it's much more useful for
me if I leave my phone in another room
for as long as possible so some in some
cases I can get to noon or 1:00 p.m.
before I even like really look at my
phone for the day one of the most
productive things I've done is not check
email until noon
now that doesn't work for everybody
job doesn't work for every situation but
if you can do something like that then
it can allow you to just focus on your
agenda rather than being pulled away on
everybody else's fires and urgencies
they need to handle well as soon as I
got a water a little glass of water just
to get the digestion started and then I
have a little math a yoga mat that I put
out outside my shower and in seven
minutes and I promise you Tiffany
they'll no longer than that I do a
series of calisthenics it's basically
Sun Salutation which say you see Ryoga
poses but then I do 100 pushups and 50
jackknife sit-ups and I do them in seven
minutes on purpose because I know I'm in
a hurry I just wanna get going it is my
equivalent of caffeine because I have
woken up by time I've done that I like
everybody else I dread doing them before
I start but as soon as I begin I'm
halfway through because they're only
seven minutes long and then they're out
of the way I have to worry about them
anymore
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because psych to go ask me to
so there's a topic you'd like to see me
cover in the next edition of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the
points in this morning routine series
you like the most is going to have the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments how are you gonna change your
routine as a result I'm really curious
to find out so leave a comment and I'm
going to join the discussion thank you
so much for watching
have an amazing day it seems to believe
and I'll see you soon